This won’t be a spoiler review since I feel like
there isn’t a major rush for people to see this
show and the good word of mouth surrounding
Andor is slowly bringing more attention to
it. Within Andor’s praise, you have probably
heard that this is the best star wars content
in a long time and technically that is true, but
to be fair there isn’t a lot of competition. The
Book of Boba Fett was pretty bad, Obi-Wan was a
nightmare behind the scenes and on screen, and
the Mandalorian is good at times, but it has its
own issues. Andor is a clear standout in quality,
however, don’t go in expecting a magnum opus
that is going to blow your socks off. This
is a slow-paced show that takes its time with
characters and plot progression and everything it
sets out to achieve is done superbly and pretty
much flawlessly. This show is a spy thriller,
with a big emphasis on drama. And with that kind
of emphasis, you need to create a colorful cast
of characters. Ironically out of all the Star Wars
content, Andor has the most interesting ensemble.
Which is really sad considering Obi-Wan just
came out and that show was so dull in terms of
character work. For Andor, we have Cassian who
is a good POV character for the audience since
he’s getting ushered into this new rebel world. He
feels very compelling because he’s so reluctant to
join the cause and is instead swayed by his own
motivations. He’s not blindly joining the rebels
for unknown reasons the writers don’t elaborate
on, but he acts realistically to serve himself.
This in turn makes the plot a bit unpredictable
because it doesn’t go down that stereotypical
path of the protagonist turning into an immediate
good guy. Then the supporting cast I think is rock
solid and there are even some Game of Thrones
alumni who show up like Lord Royce, the Waif,
and Qyburn who all do an excellent job. As well as
some other notable supporting characters like Ebon
Moss, and i’m not sure how to say his last name,
who was amazing in The Bear, and Andy Serkis. I
adore Andy Serkis and I really hope he gets more
live-action work because this man can act and he
had an engrossing monologue that’s filled with
so much emotion. Then this isn’t even getting
into the best part of the cast which is Stellan
Skarsgard. If this guy chooses a project then
I’m immediately interested in it given that he’s
been on a hot streak and if he’s choosing Andor
of all shows to be in, then there has to be
a reason. He is a world-class actor and any
line of dialogue he delivers is done with so much
weight and gravitas. His character in this show
is by far the most engaging because he’s at the
center of the rebellion so any plot development
around him is always riveting. This also ties into
mon Mothma because she’s also at the center of the
rebellion big bang. Every scene she is in has so
much tension because she has to act very carefully
so she doesn’t set off any red flags. This ties
in a more political and scheming aspect to the
show that it kind of shares with Game of Thrones.
It actually makes the conflict of starting the
rebel network a surprising delight because of
how difficult it is here. Characters don’t just
snap their fingers and spawn in allies like in the
movies, because that actually takes time and lots
of hard work. This is where the meat of Andor
is and since the writing is really well done,
it excels in these dramatic aspects. Probably
because this show is being passionately made
by Tony Gilroy who also wrote Rogue one and the
bourne trilogy, so the man is GOATED. This isn’t
a case of Obi-Wan where Disney forces it into
existence and butchers the original direction
of the story to fill the mini-series format. So
the fact that this show both has a great and solid
direction from a creative leader who is dedicated
to the project, and great actors who want to be in
this show speaks volumes for the quality of Andor.
Along with the fact that this actually feels like
a feature-length show. Because Disney Plus shows
have been gaining the reputation of being like
30 minutes long once you disregard the intro and
outro. Andor has a few episodes of that duration,
but most of them are about 40 to 50 minutes long.
So that’s another sign that the creators are
putting care into the story instead of rushing to
a conclusion. There is no filler like the endless
amount of side quests in The Mandalorian and half
of the book of boba fett being flashbacks. Andor
follows different perspectives in this expansive
universe and it all intertwines in a glorious
fashion. Now going into this show it starts out
pretty slow and I honestly had a hard time getting
through the first two episodes given that they had
to set-up a lot of material like dozen characters,
background and motivations, and Cassian’s
backstory. The plot wasn’t that engaging at
that point, but it evolves and becomes more
interesting once Cassian becomes entangled
with the rebels. The second he gets into
a room with Stellan Skarsgard’s character,
it becomes really fun. So if you do decide to
try the show, at least get to episode 3 because
the first 3 episodes have one big arc. And the
other mini plot arcs that Cassian goes down get
even better. Also, Andor doesn’t appeal to people
who want constant action and lightsaber battles.
It has action in small quantity and the show earns
it by properly building it up and having extremely
satisfying payoff. As an example, Cassian meets
a crew of people and they decide to do a heist.
And instead of having a fast pace where right
after meeting them they cut to the mission,
Cassian instead has to learn the operation and
in turn meets the characters. Everyone is very
fleshed out because of this and they all have
compelling backstories. So when we inevitably
get to the action, which is also really well done
from a writing standpoint and a visual standpoint,
we actually care about these people. Another
big aspect of this show in terms of plot and
writing is that there isn’t a constant barrage
of terrible mistakes. There’s no Leia getting
chased through the woods by bounty hunters who
can’t catch her, or characters surviving getting
skewered by a lightsaber. Andor feels realistic
and grounded and there is nothing in the writing
department that compromises that feeling. Because
of this and the more slow pace, the show feels
significantly more gritty and foreboding.
And since we are slowing down, the writers
also give the villains over in the empire a lot
of screen time. At first, I was kind of scared
these scenes would be dull since it’s a bunch of
old people talking about security and politics,
but that isn’t the case. The rendition of the
empire here is very competent and makes them seem
much more menacing because they are constantly on
the heels of our heroes and tracking them. That’s
why these scenes are so engaging because they
are directly tied to the plot, they are setting
up new and interesting characters, there’s even
conflict amongst the ranks to add even more spice,
and it’s actively intriguing because we’ve never
seen this kind of meticulous detail before in Star
Wars. That’s one major aspect about this show
that I love so much because Star Wars has such
a rich and immersive universe, but because
of bad past writers on different projects,
they essentially squander the potential of the
IP and it becomes very bland as a result. Tony
Gilroy brings in that much-needed feeling of depth
and fully explores everything tied to the rebels,
the empire, and how each planet is being impacted.
Thankfully, this detail within the world builds
the empire as stronger antagonists and doesn’t
portray them as buffoons. It makes them feel like
a real and tangible threat that is pursuing our
heroes. Which thankfully there isn’t an annoying
amount of stormtroopers constantly missing to
make the villain un-antagonizing like in Obi
Wan. Because when shit goes down, some characters
that you come to like will die. The show in that
regard isn’t afraid of killing characters and
that’s refreshing because it doesn’t give off the
notion of plot armor that destroys any semblance
of tension. It makes the action significantly
more intense despite us knowing that Cassian will
survive until the events of Rogue One. Because we
don’t know the outcome of different side
characters and how certain story elements will
play out. That’s why the show has to establish
likable characters and they do that expertly.
Going into a more technical and production point
of view for Andor, the show still doesn’t show
any flaws. For starters, every set piece is really
refreshing and is much needed since almost every
show so far has been set in the dullness of
Tatooine. Like we have a mining planet that
is being destabilized by the empire, a more
mountainous planet that looks like the best
parts of Scotland, Coruscant is back, and all
the interiors for the empire are so eerie and
corporate and is so devoid of life given that
everything is washed out in white. Essentially
contrasting the rest of the production design in
the show. This was really the first time that I’ve
been impressed by the sets for Disney+ Star Wars
content, and I’m happy that they are giving the
show a bigger sense of scale than The Mandalorian
as an example. If they were using the volume
regularly then they easily fooled me because it
looks like they are using practical locations and
using VFX as a form of set extension. I tend to
prefer this more because it makes the world feel
tangible when you really build it. It’s infinitely
more impressive to me and is awe-inspiring. The
volume used well can perfectly blend into
an already existing collection of good sets,
but when you primarily use the volume it
can become a little noticeable. For the VFX,
this isn’t a show that requires a lot of it
since there isn’t a big action set piece in
every episode, so it’s primarily used to ground
us in the world through environments. Disney is
not sparing any expense and the VFX is very
immersive because it brings a staggering
amount of quality to the details of each world.
And even when there is an emphasis on VFX like
this tie fighter flying overhead, it’s very
realistic. Like just watch this brief clip.
Through the interaction with the environment and
the characters being scared to death and being
deafened by the loud noises establishes this
as being real. Then when the show decides to
go big with VFX it really blows you away with the
striking visual design. Andor is just a beautiful
show and even the cinematography doesn’t miss a
single beat. The show hooked me really early on
with this long take focused on a close-up of
Cassian’s face as he’s being pestered by two
officers. It immediately allowed Diego Luna
to impress us with his great acting and it
was a very bold shot. So right away, the show
establishes a high bar for cinematography. The
music is also a major standout as well. This isn’t
like Obi-Wan where you probably have no memory of
what the main theme was, because here, it’s very
memorable. The composer for Andor is also the
same composer for Succession and the main theme
for that show is iconic. So to say the least,
he brings just as much talent to Andor. I
particularly love the emphasis being put
on violins and it gives a lot of the music
within this soundtrack such a beautiful and
uplifting endearing feeling. It portrays
the notion of breaking free of tyranny
and gaining freedom. Each episode opens
with a long logo of Andor and honestly,
I haven’t skipped one because I immediately am
put in a wonder-like trance by the music. That
and this soundtrack goes down some interesting
routes and the composer, Nicholas Britell, even
tries out a more synth style at times. It’s a very
refreshing soundtrack and is pretty close to The
Mandalorian in terms of quality. The Mandalorian
to me in terms of music is still my favorite,
but that’s because Ludwig Goransson is one of my
favorite composers. So yeah, everything within
this show from the acting, character work,
writing, different and fun story arcs, tone,
tense atmosphere, and everything on the production
side of the coin is done with so much expertise to
the point that it deserves to be watched. This
is a show made with so much passion and care put
into the story. It may not have characters people
love going in to immediately sell it, but it does
a magnificent job of creating a rich roster of
characters that you will easily come to love. I
was very hesitant going into the show but I ended
up binge-watching almost the whole show in one
sitting. Thank you for watching and let me
know if you guys have been enjoying Andor.